واسرائيل اختارت القاضي اراك باراك
وكل عضو من اعضاء المحكمه قبل عليه ان
يطلع بواجباته ووفق القسم وانه سيمارس
سلطاته بطريقه حياديه ووفقا للفقره 31 من
النظام الاساسي نفس هذا الشرط ينطبق على
القاضي المتخصص وقبل ان ندعو القاضي بناسك
والقاضي براك
ادلاء القسم ووفقا للتعارف عليه اود القا
سيلقون بعض الكلمات حول مؤهلاتهم القاضي
جيكان ارسن منسكي من جنوب افريقيا هو قاض
مكلل ومارس وممارس وقد حصل على درجته في
العلوم السياسيه واللغه الانجليزيه من
جامعه جنوب افريقيا والقانون وقد عمل
كمحام
وفي 2001 تم تعيينه كقاض في المحكمه
العليا في بريتوريا وفي عام لاحق اصبح قاض
في المحكمه الدستوريه في جنوب افريقيا حيث
اصبح نائب ل وزير
العدل لاعوام وفي العام 13 و 14 القاضي
مناسك ايضا هو استاذ في جامعه ال في
بريتوريا وقد خدم كمستشار في جامعه فيتوات
استان في يوهانس القاضي وسك حصل على
الكثير من اجرات الدكتوراه الفخريه
والان نتحدث عن سيره ومؤهله القاضي براك
القاضي اهران براك وهو اسرائيلي الجنسيه
هو ايضا
قاض مكلل ولاي درجه دكتوراه من جامعه
القدس وقد خدم كعميد لكليه القانون في نفس
الجامعه ما بين الفتره
وتم تعيينه كقاض في المحكمه العليا
الاسرائيليه في عام
و قبل انضمامه للمحكمه العليا في 1995 قدم
كنائب عام ما بين عام
1975 و78 وقد درس القانون في عدد من كليات
القانون بما في ذلك جامعه وجامعه هيبرو في
القدس وجامعه رايتين في هرتسليا في
اسرائيل القاضي براك ايضا عمل بشكل كبير
في القانون حس على كثير من الدرجات
الفخريه ووفقا
ل ما تنص عليه الفقره 73 من النظام
الاساسي ادعو اولا القاضي مسكي
ل ادلاء القسم المنصوص عليه وفق النظام
المؤسس وادعو من الجميع
الوقوف ج منسكي الان ال
القسم انا اقسم بانني ساقوم
بواجباتي
وامارس سلطتي
كقاض وباخلاص
وبنز و بحياديه
وبضمير حاضر اشكر القاضي منسكي والان نقضي
القاضي براك يضا ادلاء القسم وايضا وفقا
للنظام المؤسسي انا اقسم بانني سوف اقوم
بممارسه سلطاتي و واقوم بواجبي ومارس
سلطاتي كقاض بنزاهه وحياد
وايضا ضمير حاضر شكرا جزيلا لك قاضي براك
اتفضلوا
بالجلوس
الان وثقنا ادلاء القسم من قبل القاضيين
واعلن بانهما قد
سمي القاض القاضيين المتخصصين ووفقا فيما
يتعلق
بالاتفاقيه الاباده الجماعيه العام 19418
في القضيه المقدمه من قبل جنوب افريقيا ضد
اسرائيل والان نتحدث عن الاجراءات اذا في
ال9 من ديسمبر قدمت جنوب افريقيا طلب
اقامه دعوه ضد اسرائيل
بزعم عدم الوفاء بالالتزامات ضمن اتفاقيه
198 وال تتعلق بالابا الجماعيه ونحن نشير
الى هذه الاتفاقيه باسم اتفاقيه الاباده
الجماعيه من اجل اثبات اختصاص هذاه القضاء
قامت جنوب افريقيا بتفعيل الماده او 36 من
النظام مؤسس
والفقره رقم تسعه والتي تتعلق
باجراءات
و قامت بها اسرائيل حكومه اسرائيل ضد
الشعب الفلسطيني
والتي في صحوه الهجوم الذي جرى على
اسرائيل في السابع من
اكتوبر عام 2023 وبالتالي تزعم جنوب
افريقيا بان ما قامت به اسرائيل هو ذات
طبيعه اباده جماعيه واقتبس بانهم قاموا
بنيه
تدمير جزء كبير من المجموعات العرقيه
الفلسطينيه في قطاع غزه وهذه نهايه
الاقتباس وجنوب افريقيا تشدد على ان لما
قامت بالاجراءات
الاسرائيليه فش هي فشل في وفاء اسرائيل
بالتزاماتها وفق الاتفاقيه الاباده
الجماعيه وايضا التزامات اخرى ضمن
الاتفاقيه ان الطلب
يتضمن طلب اقامه الدعوه ضلب فرض التدابير
المؤقته وفق
ال الماده 37 و47 و57 من و75 ووفقا لجنوب
افريقيا واقتبس بان التدابير مؤقته ضروريه
جدا في هذه القضيه من اجل حمايه ضد اذن
شديد على حقوق الفلسطينيين مستمر وفق
الاتفاقيه والذي يستمر بانتهاك
وفلات من العقاب جنوب افريقيا تو فرض
التدابير مؤقته من اجل حمايه حقوق
الفلسطين وحقها ايضا وفقا للاتفاقيه ومنع
ايه اي ضرر تصعيد او ضرر اضافي
سيتم قراءه
الان جزء من النص الذي قدمته جنوب افريقيا
من اجل فرض التدابير
المؤقته المقرر اقتبس اولا بان دوله
اسرائيل عليها ان تتوقف فورا عملياتها
العسكريه
ضد قطاع غزه وعلى دوله اسرائيل ان تتاكد
من ان ايه عمل وحدات عسكريه
نظاميه وغير
نظاميه تتبعها او لها تاثير عليها او ايه
اشخاص قد يكونون ضمن
سيطرتها ان لا يتخذوا ايه خطوات
اضافيه
فيقيم بال العسكريه وايضا تتخذ كل من جنوب
افريقيا ودوله اسرائيل وفقا لالتزامها
بموجب اتفاقيه منع جريمه الاباده الجماعيه
والمعاقب عليها فيما يتعلق بالش
الفلسطيني اتخذ جميع التدابير المعقوله
التي هي في حدود سلطتها من اجل اباده
الاباده الجماعيه رابعا دوله اسرائيل
ستقوم وفقا لالتزاماته بموجب اتفاقيه منع
الاباده الجماعيه والمعاقب عليها فيما
يتعلق بالشعب الفلسطيني
وبموجب اتفاقيه من عن
جماعه الاباده الجماعيه والمعاقب على
الامتناع عن ارتكاب اي اي وجميع الافعال
التي تدخل في نطاق قي الماده الثانيه من
الاتفاقيه وعلى وجه الخصوص قتل
اعضاء الافراد والتسبب في ضرر جسدي او
عقلي خطير او فرض ظروف معيشيه متعمده يقصد
منها الدمار المادي كليا او جزئيا
وايضا فرض تدابير تهدف الى
ايضا المنع الولادات يجب على دوله اسرائيل
عملا
بماده الرابعه جيم اعلاه فيما تعل ال
فلسطيني توقف عن انتخاب جميع التدابير في
حدود سلطتها بما في ذلك الغاء الاوامر ذات
الصله والقيود وا او الحظر على المنع
الطرد والتشريط قصرا من منازلهم والحرمان
من اولا با واحد الحصول على الغذاء والماء
الكافي ب اثنين الحصول على المساعده
الانسانيه بما في ذلك ال الحصول على
الوقود الكافي والماوى والملبس والنظافه
وايضا الثلاثه با ثلاث الامدادات
والمساعدات
الطبيه
وايضا
دوله تضمن دوله اسرائيل فيما يتعلق
بالفلسطينيين ان جيشها وكذلك اي وحدات
مسلحه غير نظاميه او افراد قد يتم توجيههم
او دعمهم او التاثير عليهم باي شكل اخر
وكذلك اي منظمات اشخاص قد يخضعون لسلطتها
ا بشكل بالتاثير او بالامر المباشر بعدم
الامتناع عن ارتكاب ايه افعال موصوفه في
الفقره اربعه وخمسه اعلاه او تشارك في
التحريض المباشر والعلني على ارتكاب
الاباده الجماعيه او التامر لارتكاب
الاباده الجماعيه او محاولات ارتكاب
الاباده الجماعيه او التواطؤ في الاباده
الجماعيه و بقدر ما واثناء قيامهم بذلك
يتم اتخاذ الخطوات اللازمه لمعاقبه وفقا
للمواد الاولى والثانيه والثالثه والرابعه
من اتفاقيه منع جريمه الاباده الجماعيه
والمعاقب عليها
سابعا على دوله اسرائيل ان تتخذ تدابير
فعاله لمنع تدمير الادله المتعلقه
بالادعاءات بارتكاب افعال ضمن نطاق الماده
الثانيه من اتفاقيه منع جريمه الاباده
الجماعيه والمعقب عليها وضمان الحفاظ على
هذه
الادله وتحقيقا لهذا على دوله اسرائيل ان
تمتنع عن منع او تقييد وصول بعثات تقصي
الحقائق وتفويضات الد بفق التفويضات
الدوليه او الهيئات الاخرى الى غزه
للمساعده في ضمان الحفاظ على الادله
المذكوره والحفاظ عليها ثامنا يجب على
دوله اسرائيل ان تقدم تقريرا الى المحكمه
عن جميع التدابير المتخذه لتنفيذ هذا
الامر وخلال اسبوع واحد واعتبارا من تاريخ
هذا الامر وبعد ذلك على فترات منتظمه كما
تامر المحكمه
حتى صدور قرار نهائي من المحكمه تاسعا
تمتنع دوله اسرائيل عن اي
اجراء وتضمن عدم اتخاذ اي اجراءات قد يؤدي
الى تفاقم النزاع المعروض امام المحكمه او
اطاله امده او جعل حله اكثر صعوبه نهايه
الاقتباس اذكر المقرر وفورا بعد هذا
الطلب وطلب فرض التدابير المؤقته نائب
الموقر قد قدم نسخه رسميه الى حكومه
اسرائيل كما اعلم الامين العام للامم
المتحده ووفقا للماده 74 الفقره واحد من
النظام الاساسي طلب لفرض التدابير المؤقته
سيكون له اولويه على كل القضايا الاخرى
والفقره الثانيه من نفس البند تشير الى ان
المحكمه سوف تقوم بالوصول الى قرار على
قيد
الالحاح لكن ينبغي ان يكون هذا من
منطلق من منطلق تحديد مرافعات شفهيه
لاعطاء الفرس لتقديم وجهات نظرهم كما ان
الاطراف تم اعلامهم
بالتاريخ المرافعات الشفاهيه حيث تقدم
فيها الدوله الول ملاحظاتها على فرض
التدبير المؤقته وبالتالي تم تحديد هذا في
الخامس في الحادي عشر من يناير في العاشره
صباحا الان اود ان ارحب بوفد جنوب افريقيا
واسرائيل
و وحضور ممثلي ين البلدين سوف تستمع
المحكمه المرافعات الشفهيه لجنوب افريقيا
والتي قدمت طلبا لفرض التدابير المؤقته
وتستمع لاسرائيل صباح الغد في العاشره
صباحا ولغرض هذه الجوله من المرافعات
الشفهيه كل دوله سيتاح لها ثلاثه ساعات
وفي على جلسات والان الجلسه الاولى قد
تطلب جنوب افريقيا
تمديدا استثنائيا بعد الساعه الواحده وقبل
ان نعطي لك